when you go to l.a you got hired or
something to do some
cartoon as a dog or something that's
right hollywood dog
hollywood dog voice of hollywood dog and
hollywood dog was cancelled
quickly it never made it to the air it
was a pilot that never even heard but
the dude who
produced the hollywood dog or was
director i don't know what he was
but he said why don't you go in on the
simpsons it was the casting directorate
fox who happened to be a woman who knew
me from that and had me come in and read
for motherboard
holy mackerel and mo the bartender was
just you doing an impression of al
pacino right
i yeah i was doing a play in the at the
time in la i was playing a drug dealer
and i was doing a very bad pacino
early pacino like from dog day afternoon
i'm dying here
everybody's coming down on me shot i
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
here
and i did that voice and in the play in
the play
and for the audition i said well we
wanted gravely because it was based on
red you guys used to love red didn't you
yeah love red
red the bartender exactly based on that
yeah so
[Applause]
my so they wanted it gravely i hadn't
even heard that at the time so
if you make pacino gravely you'll get
motorbot
phone call for rao alcoholic
is there an alcoholic here oh that's how
you do it that's all it was do you think
that's your whole approach to acting
that you're just
mimicking other people is that what
you're doing it was for a long time
uh i would imitate people and only feel
uh that i was actually being interesting
if i was being somebody else and i could
vocally kind of do that
it took me sort of years to trust that i
could just be myself and maybe be
so when you were a little kid like as
young as five years old you were one of
those kids that watched tv non-stop
right totally and you could mimic
everyone on television
true that is totally how i started but
you didn't see it as a gift or you
didn't see it as
you just assumed everyone in the world
could
do impressions that is right you have
done your research well sir yes
uh yes i didn't realize it was an
ability a special
ability to be able to sound like
whatever you heard i just thought
everybody
and what were you watching like cartoons
at five i assumed the same [ __ ] that i
was watching with
cartoons and and uh mel blanc and all
that my hero was in fact bugs bunny
and then about age 11 i was told that's
a guy you know that's a man doing all
those voices then mel blanc became my
hero
isn't that funny like mel blank became
your hero now like you're i would say
on par with mel blanc in terms of doing
your career and and being all these
voices on the simpsons
i certainly have done a lot of cartoon
work i would never put myself i'm sure
fred will agree with this i would never
he was a genius him and everybody else
right right he was the best
he was amazing but yes i've gotten to
live out a dream i didn't even know i
had really